[Música]
tiene un castaño conectara y levante la
mano quien pagaría por ponerse la
celeste y blanca y jugar un mundial para
argentina
bastantes o sea es tan loco no estaba
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a otra escala no pero en 2016 la
selección argentina universitaria de
fútbol se clasificó para el mundial de
este año que se disputaba en agosto en
kazajistán pero el problema al que se
enfrentaban estos estudiantes es que el
deporte universitario esa materia en
nuestro país con lo cual la federación
no podía afrontar la participación así
que como todos los que levantaron la
mano tenían que rebuscárselas para
pagarse para poder participar pero
imagínense que ir a kasajistán almaty no
es lo mismo que ir a mar del plata
alguien sabe dónde está casa que están
adelante la mano quien podría ubicarlo
en un mapa
no tantos me importa esta casa que están
entre kirguistán uzbekistán tayikistán y
türkmenistán fácil bueno y aunque está
cerca de china o sea lejos bien lejos 15
mil 309 kilómetros para ser exactos
ahora imagínense lo que sale un pasaje
atacas aquí es tan así que justamente
había que organizarse con tiempo pero
por suerte tenían dos años porque el
técnico ni corro si es el número uno de
acá de tigre armó el equipo con 30
jugadores
faltando dos años para el mundial y el
plantel puso las reglas claras los 30
hacemos parte de grupos los 30 juntamos
la plata los 30 entrenamos y cuando el
técnico de la lista eran los 14 que
tengan que ir eso ya me parecía como la
primera muestra de madurez de este grupo
para encontrar 30 pibes dispuestos a
entrenar durante dos años y juntar
dinero durante dos años para niños
mundiales que más de la mitad se quedara
afuera era como guau estos pibes están
metidos y fue lo primero que me
entusiasmó desde que me tocó acompañar
este proceso no lo dije antes estoy
contando la historia porque soy el
manager de este equipo
cuestión que durante los dos años nos
pusimos a diseñar estrategias para
recaudar fondos no inventamos la pólvora
hicimos las típicas cosas rifas fiestas
partidos a beneficio amistosos torneos
entonces en el marco de esos eventos
aprovechamos para organizar buffet y
vender comida eso genera una dinámica
bastante piedra que es que se empiezan a
involucrar los familiares de los
jugadores ayudando en el buffet bueno
fueron dos años intensos pero lindos
porque además de juntar dinero había que
entrenar estaba siendo mundial con lo
cual estos pibes que estudiaban de día
trabajaban de tarde entrenarán con sus
clubes de noche jugaban con sus clubes
los fines de semana como después o
tenían tanto tiempo libre además
entrenaron con la selección
universitaria y además juntaban dinero
para viajar
faltando dos meses para el mundial y
para él y un mes para el panamericano
que era un mes antes en san pablo el
técnico dio la lista de los 14 que
habían sido elegidos para viajar pero
nos llevamos a juntar el dinero y el
pasaje de todos sumados millón de pesos
imagínense que juntar un millón de pesos
en dos años no es tarea sencilla así que
cada uno tuvo que completarse como pudo
lo que le faltaba algunos con ahorros
otros con ayudar familias en algunos
casos ayudaron intendentes diputados
bueno y los rectores de las
universidades cada uno como pudo hasta
que bueno en todo ese proceso también
nos dedicamos a buscar pasajes
obviamente con 950 escalas 600 horas de
vuelo para poder abaratar los costos
como sea y en esa búsqueda dimos con una
gente que me dejaba muy buenos precios
así que sacamos los pasajes
estábamos después de dos años pero el
entusiasmo que teníamos era tremendo
el emitir admite yo ya había prendido
por youtube hablar en casa y todos están
metidísimos con la quitan
pero nos estafaron
nos [ __ ] el millón de pesos que
habíamos juntado a los pasajes no nos
robaron habían acuerdo el momento con
interés estábamos en el panamericano que
les conté antes están pablo me quedé
helado falla tengo un audio que le mande
una compañera de laburo le dije me
infarto siete veces entonces segundos
creo que para ti no sea un récord
guinness lo primero que hice fue hablar
con mi jefe que se presente la
federación que se quedó helado igual que
yo pero hicimos un clic y entramos en
razón de que había que hacer lo que sea
para poder viajar y que no nos roben
este sueño mundial que teníamos lo
primero era hablar con los chicos que
estaban conmigo en san pablo pero miren
este
estas eran ellos
en el momento que yo me entero por
teléfono que nos haya estafado encontré
esa en la red se les hace el finés las
caras que tenían no podía cortarles el
mambo estábamos yendo a la ceremonia de
apertura de los juegos yo estaba a 30
metros esa foto literalmente así
literal me había hecho el fotógrafo fue
genial no tan genial pero bueno no podía
cortarles hermano de esa manera así que
lo asiste en mi habitación en el hotel a
la vuelta ahí traté de ser lo más
directo posible
muchachos nos estafaron nos [ __ ] nos
robaron el millón de pesos pero quédense
tranquilos
silencio
si te desborda más tranquilidad si sólo
nos acaba de decir que nos robaron en
emisión de pesos que estamos juntando
hace dos años para cumplir el sueño
nuestra vida no misión es eso pero
seguro lo pensaron le dije todo lo que
tenía para decirles pero pero decidí
como apelar a una cita de autoridad para
darle más fuerza a mi mensaje entonces
se aprende a unos conceptos introducidos
por un pensador contemporáneo para
recuperarlos y que se llama rotundo el
mensaje entonces en ese momento le pasa
este vídeo
la palabra crisis también quiere decir
oportunidad si oportuno crisis tienes
razón
no claramente no le pase este vídeo se
imagina en la habitación después decirle
me acaban a trompadas pero no le pasa
que siempre hay un ejemplo los simpson
para todos no importa vuelvo
imagínense las caras en esa habitación
en ese momento de angustia bronca
desolación enojo miedo frustración
eso es una frase típica en kazajistán
pensar que en un minuto te puede cambiar
la vida te puede cambiar todo recibir
una noticia así tan imposible digerir en
un momento que puede cambiar casi todos
tonos
porque la actitud de compromiso la
dedicación el esfuerzo el sacrificio la
voluntad todo lo que hayan habéis hecho
traspié durante esos dos años estaba ahí
latente
había que hacer algo con eso así que
estuvimos hasta la una de la mañana en
la habitación buscándole la vuelta y
decidimos que íbamos a hacer lo que sea
para viajar
así que nos metimos con estrategias
recorrer todos los medios de
comunicación instalar la problemática y
de esta manera acudir a la solidaridad
de la sociedad civil del sistema
político de los empresarios de quien sea
nos faltan 20 días para viajar a todo
esto para juntar un millón de pesos pero
recuerden estamos en brasil con lo cual
reales para gestionar teníamos 11 días y
yo no soy economista como matías pero
también me gusta hacer números 11 de
ellas son 15 mil 800 minutos o 950 mil
400 segundos o sea en 950.000 400
segundos tenemos juntar un millón de
pesos o sea cada segundo que pasaba hay
que juntar un peso 47 o sea en esta
charla que llevo acá con ustedes me
perdí la posibilidad recuperar mil 323
pesos así que si les gusta la charla
afuera tanto muchacho pasando la gorra
la charla está en mi habitación terminó
a la una de la mañana
a todo esto al día siguiente de gustamos
en el panamericano pero hicimos el clic
y a las 8 de la mañana ya estábamos
saliendo a vía telefónica en un
noticiero eso generó un efecto contagio
que no paró el es nicolás pique que es
el capitán del equipo estudia educación
física y trabajaba organizando eventos
deportivos porque ahí tuvo que hacer un
parate y se dedicó a recorrer estudio de
televisión como si fuera una estrella de
hollywood salimos en todos los
noticieros del país y sin timo más de 30
entrevistas radiales salimos en todos
los diarios más importantes del país en
todos los portales de noticias
fernanda william que es el capitán de la
selección argentina que es la actual
campeona del mundo subió un vídeo a sus
redes sociales contando nuestra
problemática y atrás de él todo el
plantel hizo lo mismo viendo la gente
que nos ayude a dos toques y paseamos
funchal que salgado el medio que se
encargan de cubrir escuchar se pusiera
al hombre una campaña solidaria
la organización deportiva universitaria
de centroamérica y el caribe nos mandó
una nota convocándonos como invitado de
honor el año que viene a los juegos
centroamericanos y del caribe la
federación internacional de deporte
universitario también nos mandó una nota
colaborando con nosotros los directores
de deporte de todas las universidad del
país que integran la federación del
deporte universitario se pusieron desde
tierra del fuego hasta misiones a vender
una contribución para que los chicos
puedan viajar
en el minuto 1 que pasa la problemática
nos llamaron de la afa y desde el
presidente hasta el último club de la
última categoría se pusieron a
disposición nos organizaron un amistoso
nuestro equipo contra la selección
argentina campeona del mundo para
despedirnos a canchallena a la cancha de
ferro y ver si podíamos recaudar fondos
con ese evento que además se ha
televisado en vivo para todo el país
cuestión
después de tanto movernos
el día es en ferro llegamos a juntar el
millón de pesos que nos faltaba para
poder viajar en 10 días
pero me van a crear
no no
imaginen si estamos en agosto pleno
contexto de evaluación se disparó el
dólar y con el dólar seis parados los
pasajes juntamos un palo en diez días y
nos faltaban 450 mil pesos todavía no es
gracioso
y cinco días para viajar pero imagínense
no hay vamos a rendirnos ahí así que
seguimos golpeando puertas de cualquier
persona intendente diputados senadores
concejales si hubieran presidente del
mundo hubieran buscado su oficina
debíamos golpear las puertas y nos
tiraba abajo y entre tanto movernos
nos tocó después de tanta jugar
preparadas meter un golazo bueno hacer
como este que lo voy a mostrar
literalmente como ese que fue el gol más
lindo del mundial universitario y no
metido lautaro por nicole y de argentina
una estudiante educación física de la
unlu alcalá así después de tantas idas y
vueltas pudimos viajar al mundial y fue
lo más maravilloso que nos pasó en toda
nuestra vida
en nuestra habitación para que miren
teníamos hasta una lunes figurita del
equipo déjate de [ __ ] no había forma de
no viajar si aparecían profesionales de
base represento a los muchachos que
fueron los héroes que se mandaron todas
esa quien esconde
al final algo de razón tenía menos con
esto el aporte en crisis terminamos
saliendo en todos lados todo el mundo
sabía nosotros nos terminó despidiendo
la selección argentina campeona del
mundo en ferro a estadio lleno
televisado en vivo el día que nos fuimos
en ezeiza
la gente nos reconocía mira gordo solo
el fútbol sé que juntaron la plata le
dijo una señora a su pareja otra vez en
caro
sólo ustedes lo lograron no dijo antes
emocionada y sorprendida el tití borruto
es uno de los 14 campeones del mundo con
argentina viajó en nuestro mismo vuelo
tremenda casualidad cuestión quisimos
vamos a una foto con él va al más
caradura encararlo para contarle quiénes
éramos
titi mirada disculpa lo interrumpe nos
disculpen ustedes muchachos que no me
aferro perdón no pude ir no reconoció ya
nosotros no pidió perdón por no ella
ferro la noticia incluso cruzó el océano
antes que nosotros porque en esta
búsqueda del pasaje barato
teníamos una escala en españa donde
vamos a entrenar llegamos a madrid no
estaban esperando la embajada argentina
no funciona un micro disposición nos
llevaron a comer nos llevaron a conocer
la cancha de real madrid la prensa real
madrid no se entrevistaban nosotros
real
nos llevará entre a las mejores canchas
del mundo fuimos al entrenamiento al
inter movistar el inter movistar es el
mejor equipo de fichas del mundo fuimos
a entrenar al haber el entrenamiento de
ellos y entrenamos en su cancha para los
pies era un sueño hay entrenan sus
ídolos después de entrenamientos no hay
una vista de ricardinho es el mejor
jugador del mundo gana dos últimos
cuatro balones de oro de la fifa
incluso cuando llegamos al mundial todos
nuestros rivales sabían nuestra historia
la experiencia maravillosa estadios
llenos con 15.000 espectadores fue
tremendo como no nos tocan obstáculos
para superar nos tocó el grupo de la
muerte llegamos al último partido
teniendo que ganar 6 a 0 si no nos
quedamos afuera estaba self y el 7 a 0
contra eslovaquia
que nos permitió clasificar a cuartos de
final no metido entre los ocho mejores
el mundo y nos clasificamos al mundial
2020 en polonia pero no sea tanto
queremos conseguir los pasajes
los pies hasta firman autógrafos literal
firmaron remeras alguna algunas firmadas
zapatillas de muchachos de estos
firmando de zapatillas de los niños
casas era una locura
pero realmente nuestro codo de verdad
vivir un sueño mundial
qué lindo que te caen
no tremendo le quiero agradecer
profundamente a la persona que no hace
esta foto de esa manera y no robo un
millón de pesos
no hay nada para decirle porque además
de nosotros y me pongo un poco serio
stafford otras 2000 personas que todavía
están sufriendo mucho y realmente pero
que muy pronto se haga justicia pero
quien no hubiera dicho que una crisis
tan tremenda como la que nos tocó pasar
podamos haber reaccionado como grupo y
que se desencadenen todas estas cosas
maravillosas que les conté que no
pasaron
saben que de todo corazón
pero de todo corazón les quiero decir
que algún día los carguen pero bien cada
dos y le roban un millón de pesos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]